[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the bride of bill weasley
and french quarter villa
more specifically however we're going to
be discussing her performance
during the triwizard tournament in the
goblet of fire
flo is a talented witch and the student
of bobaton
in fact she was chosen as her school's
champion
so why did she keep getting the short
end of the stick
what gives the try wizard tournament is
a contest
like no other an event dating back more
than 700 years
that tests the intelligence courage and
strength
of those participating since its
inception the contest has gone forward
every five years
with a brief 200 year pause due to
all three champions being injured in
typically the tournament featured three
champions one from each of the three
largest wizarding schools in europe
durmstrang mobitol and hogwarts these
school champions would then take place
in three brutal challenges
three participants three challenges
hence try
wizard tournament the prize of the
tournament was eternal glory
1000 galleons and the famed tri-wizard
cup
however harry potter sort of
unintentionally broke this mould
as during his time at hogwarts his name
was thrown in as an
extra participant in the year that harry
participated
there were four harry potter victor crum
cedric diggory
and to the focus of this video flor de
la cour accounts of the tournament vary
a little from book to film
but the general idea of the tournament
was the same three challenges
one other constant was fleur's
performance which quite frankly
wasn't there as she tailed behind the
other three participants
for the duration of the tournament the
first challenge was to retrieve a golden
egg
from one of four immensely powerful and
dangerous dragons
each champion was paired with the dragon
and ended up obtaining the egg in their
own
unique way harry opted to take advantage
of his flying skills
crum utilized a conjunctivitis curse
cedric used
transfiguration and fleur who faced a
common welsh green
chose to enchant the dragon to sleep
everyone was successful in obtaining the
egg
however for some it was not without
hiccups
though fleur's enchantment worked and
the dragon was put to sleep
she faced issues when the dragon snored
releasing a jet of flame
this jetta flame set her skirt alight
but she was still able to put the flames
out
and retrieve her egg fleur's issues
resulted in a fourth place finish
last the second challenge was at the
great lake a challenge involving water
mer people and something that the
participants would
sorely miss the thing that the
participants would miss
however ended up being important people
in their lives
strangely enough hermione was crumb's
rescue e
ron was harry's cho chang was cedric's
and gabrielle
her younger sister was fleurs given one
hour
the participants were tasked with saving
these individuals
and once again each ended up pursuing it
in their own
individual way though fleur figured out
how to breathe underwater
she still had considerable difficulty
with the challenge in fact
harry ended up saving more than his own
champion out of fear that they would die
if left unsaved
harry looked around waiting where were
fleur and crum
time was getting short and according to
the song the hostages would be lost
after an hour because fleur hadn't yet
arrived to save her sister
harry acted hastily thinking that she
would die if he didn't take action
harry's selflessness meant that he ended
up with the third place finish
however that placing was later revised
to second for
showing moral fiber fleur once again
finished in last
going into the third task harry and
diggory were tied for first
crown was second and fleur was in third
aka fourth
make a blast the third task involved a
20-foot high maze full of obstacles
riddles and creatures participants would
have to circumnavigate the maze
overcome the obstacles and claim the
triwizard cup from there the winner
would bask in eternal glory
things didn't look good for fleur
however as she went into the third task
with two fourth place finishers under
her belt in the end
flu got last in this challenge as well
though i'm sure it could be argued that
cedric
the boy who died had the biggest loss
that day
because she was in last place entering
the third task she was last to enter the
maze
behind cedric harry and victor in the
end harry and cedric raced to the
tri-wizard cup
together sharing first place just before
being transported to the little
hangalton graveyard
fleur on the other hand didn't make it
far in the maze at all
as fake alastair moody aka barty crouch
jr
couldn't help but meddle with the
tournament upon entering the maze
flo was stunned by crouch jr eliminating
any chance she ever had of winning
not that it was looking good anyway so
why did fleur perform so badly
well it was for a variety of reasons in
the first challenge blue simply got
unlucky putting the dragon to sleep is a
totally valid way of approaching that
challenge
and her ability to put the dragon to
sleep in the first place speaks volumes
to her magical ability
i completely understand why she
approached the dragon challenge in that
way
and in my opinion her mishap doesn't
indicate any level of
incompetence so challenge number one
fleur was just unlucky
nothing more the second challenge
however was fleur's fault
she performed the worst there and that's
not because she isn't talented but
it's because someone has to perform the
worst and the competition was fierce
the triwizard tournament has high stakes
particularly the second challenge
where the participants were under the
impression that this was a life or death
situation
at least harry was some people just
crumble under pressure
and i think that's what happened to
fleur here as far as she was concerned
a little sister was in grave danger and
i think that the pressure was just too
much for her
i think if anything the second challenge
is the best indication of why i think
that fleur
deserves a last place finish it's not
that she isn't a good person
or that she isn't magically talented but
she simply performed the worst here
however with all of that said let's not
ignore the elephant in the room here
harry had a lot of help not only that
but at this stage of the books
fleur had the weakest relationship to
harry of all of the competitors
and had the least influence on the
narrative this is where the door list or
authorial perspective should be
considered the idea that certain plot
points and the development of the story
are largely influenced by the real world
motivations of the story's creator
haru was always going to win the
tournament i don't think that you could
argue that he's the main protagonist the
books are named after him
and if he lost it should all be a bit
tragic this means that the only
unknown to the reader is who will take
second third and fourth place
in this sort of situation these next
positions are whether you like it or not
influenced by how relevant the
characters are to the story flow getting
lost
doesn't necessarily mean she was the
worst though she may have been
it just means that she had the smallest
connection to harry our main protagonist
at this point in the story cedric was
always going to tie for first with harry
because cedric's destiny was
pre-ordained
he was destined to travel to the little
hangalton graveyard alongside harry
where he would later die okay so that
now means that the first and second
slots are
occupied this leaves only third and
fourth place and
these positions were basically decided
by fake moody one of them was going to
be stunned and another was going to be
put under the imperious curse
and it just so happened that fleur was
the one who was stunned
bearing this in mind let's briefly take
a look at the challenges once again
in the first task harry sort of has to
win winning proves that harry is a
worthy competitor in the tournament
and it just wouldn't make sense for him
to have come last cedric couldn't come
last either
because in the eyes of hogwarts he was
the true champion the one truly
deserving of a placement in the
tournament
if he had gotten last and harry had
gotten first it just wouldn't have made
any sense this brings us to crum crum
was often described and referred to as
impressive
if the tournament had started and he
kicked things off with a last place
finish
it would have been quite unusual this
leaves only fleur
and though fleur had arguably the best
method of dealing with the dragon
putting it to sleep making her last sort
of came out of plot convenience
this same logic sort of carries on to
the second challenge where fleur
actually fails one champion had to fail
and look bad
so that harry would be under the
impression that people going to drown
if there wasn't that same sense of
urgency then harry wouldn't have acted
in the way that he did
as for the third challenge well she just
got unlucky
third and fourth were reserved for crum
and fleur and it just so happens that
fleur
was the last to enter as well as the one
who was stunned by party crouch jr
so again why did fleur do so badly well
it turns out that by the time the goblet
of fire rolled around her character had
the smallest relationship to harry and
the tournament
this almost meant that she was destined
to fail in a recreation of the
tournament she actually could have done
really well but if she had then it just
wouldn't have worked as well for the
story
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time you're a wizard harry
you